Trump's economic adviser, Larry Kudlow, was
visibly confused and sounded off when it came
to simple arithmetic on CNN yesterday.
I think you'll find this disturbing because
it is wild confusion about basic numbers,
combined with a very odd delivery from Larry
Kudlow, which we'll talk about in a moment.
Now, the setup is that there has been a debate
about what is the next stimulus package going
to include?
When is the next emulous package going to
happen?
What's the unemployment piece and how does
it all fit together?
Larry Kudlow puts together a word salad where
it's not even clear he knows the numbers.
He certainly can't express them, but it's
not even clear he knows what the numbers are.
CNN's Dana Bash tries to figure out what the
hell is Larry Kudlow talking about?
She can't do it.
Kudlow is confused and it all falls apart
today.
So when there were four months of tax.
I don't want to be as specific as you might
hold me to it as you should, but I think it's
going to be in a couple of weeks and I think
it's going to come to about 12 hundred dollars
per person.
That's a huge change.
One hundred dollars per person.
Are you talking about in addition to the unemployment
that they're already getting?
And that's something he wrote that to answer.
I beg your pardon?
The twelve hundred dollars will come from
the payroll tax deferred.
We're going to get to the heart of this.
All right.
Because this is there's a lot of numbers are
it's looking to see how many should be a tax
in a minute.
Go ahead.
It should be 800 bucks.
I beg your pardon?
It should be 800 bucks for the unemployment.
Eight hundred or four hundred.
No, it should before it should be eight hundred
dollars.
If the states step up, we're prepared to match.
That should be come out.
Four hundred dollars federal.
Four hundred dollar states.
OK, I will move on, because I think this is
that's not what the president said and it's
a bit confusing and I think the fact that
it's not entirely known is very telling.
Twelve hundred per person payroll tax deferral.
Wait, no stimulus.
Actually, it should be eight hundred for unemployment.
No, it were prepared to match 400 federal
and 400 state.
But we're matching.
Wait.
But what does that even mean?
You're matching 400 federal.
There's really nothing federal to match.
It's all state when it comes to unemployment.
And then the federal match or enhancement
is of state unemployment insurance.
If you think I sound confused.
Yes.
It's because it's this insane what Larry Kudlow
is saying.
He's saying there's a state match and a federal
match.
What does that even mean?
And Dana, Dana Bash, just white flags.
She surrenders and she says, let's move on.
This is totally confusing.
It's not what Donald Trump is saying now.
The second layer is that not only is Larry
Kudlow presenting this in a completely impossible
to understand way, it also seems to be completely
different from what the Trump what Donald
Trump himself has said.
And when we talk about this matching the Fed's
contribute three hundred dollars if the states
add another hundred.
But I'm trying to sort out something as if
it's at all clear.
And Kudlow just was slightly confused.
He seems to have no idea what's going on whatsoever,
and it gets even worse during this interview.
Here's a similar confusion about the payroll
tax deferral.
Not a cut, a deferral.
And Larry Kudlow equally confused.
But the president said explicitly that if
he gets reelection reelected, he will make
the payroll tax cut permanent.
As you well know, these funds, these funds
go into and help pay for Social Security and
Medicare.
The president promised many times not to do
things for security and Medicare.
So isn't that exactly just what to do here?
No.
He will protect Social Security.
And how did he do that and cut payroll taxes
at that time?
Well, hang on.
When he referred to permanent, I think what
he was saying is that the deferral of the
payroll tax to the end of the year will be
made permanent.
It will be forgiven.
The tax is not going away.
We're still going to have that.
He later he said he would do acting if he
gets reelected.
It was a campaign pledge.
But no, I think that he was referring doing
away with that.
I believe he was referring to doing away with
the pay back of the deferral.
And I think his intent here and it's written
and the CEOs very clear that we will take
any steps possible to forgive this deferral.
That's what he is actually saying.
We will.
I just want to say I just want to say that.
Yes, Atika, that is not that is not what the
president said at all.
He said he said this is a serious earthquake.
OK.
It said that's what he said.
People aren't reading the executive order.
They're listening to that.
I think it is.
I think he meant I think he meant the deferral
would be forgiven.
I think he was saying that that the savings
on deferral will be permanent, meaning that
he's eliminating the Social Security tax.
It's a deferral that will be forgiven without
doing away with the tax.
But Trump said he would do away with it if
he's reelected.
But that's not what Trump meant, according
to Kudlow.
If you were confused and you were confused
further by my explanation.
Good.
It's outrageously confusing and deceptive.
And this is either it's either or both.
You take your pick there either all deliberately
saying different things in order to sort of
let everybody take their pick.
And if they hear one version that sounds OK,
they like it and they say, I approve or they
actually don't know what the hell is going
on.
And everybody's saying something different
or some combination.
Right.
That that's always a possibility.
We need to hear from Kudlow what Trump meant,
apparently.
I mean, Kudlow is saying what the president
meant is this absolutely outrageous and bizarre.
Now, I do have to mention one thing to go
back to Larry Kudlow demeanor here.
People have been e-mailing me saying, is Kudlow
drunk again during this interview?
I understand why you are asking.
Larry Kudlow does have a history of problems
when it comes to alcohol consumption.
That's not anything to laugh at.
I don't know the answer in this case, but
certainly it's not a crazy thing to wonder
about with Larry Kudlow.
His thinking clearly seemed impaired.
He was visibly confused by the arithmetic
and by what he's saying and by what he's being
asked and by what Donald Trump said and by
what Donald Trump meant.
It's a, you know, a verbal inkblot.
As I like to say, as far as the alcohol piece
is concerned, I don't know, it's it's up to
others to evaluate and judge.
His thinking was impaired by what is definitely
a different question that I guess we will
have to leave, presumably for a different
day